tenez ça fait juste 100 grammes de
bonbons +2 chacun deux et deux font
quatre
bonjour vous avez vu comme elle compte
bien je suis très heureuse de vous
accueillir dans l'île aux enfants
oui savez-vous qui si tout le monde est
guéri et heureux évidemment sauf moi
solutions parfois m'enfin c'est
l'exception regardez françois comme il
était à l'essai ballon et jeudi avec six
gros et on suit regardez moi vous croyez
pas qu'il faut avoir une forme
extraordinaire pour faire ça bravo
casimir dit dis moi elle m'a l'air en
pleine forme aujourd'hui
oui je viens de découvrir que dans l'île
tout le monde était heureux ça c'est
vrai tu as parlé de marie julie
percevoir que tout le monde
oui bah si vous pensez ça c'est vous
fait un bruit énorme a dansé comme deux
éléphants est pendante mais que veux tu
dire écoutez je vois vraiment pas c'est
que rien à voir entre un éléphant et moi
un éléphant c'est gros et tétouan
casimir écoute aussi vous entendez
j'entends bien j'ai pas d'oreilles
effectivement il ya quelqu'un qui pleure
aussi sûrement monsieur du snap qui fait
ça pour m'embêter génome et non bio
casimir il arrive parfois à monsieur
10,9 de gémir ou de hurler les cheminots
ne pleurerait doucement bon tu connais
toi il ferait n'importe quoi pour moi
nuillé sont choqués du mur monsieur du
ch n'a pas autre chose à faire jeter sur
évidemment leur toi tu prend toujours la
défense de monsieur liste noire comprend
moi quand j'ai vraiment jeu casimir de
janeiro dire julie oui d'ailleurs je les
mets sur l'île et welsh et les jolies
voulu jouer vu ça lors jolie elle a dû
apprendre un tour de magie et disparaît
aux coûteuses unir mais noël est parti
tandis que nous étions en train de
bavarder tous les deux
casimir regarde et jules et là-bas
allons l'avoir combat oui à temps elle
est avec quelqu'un c'est peut-être
dangereux bravo casimir alors s'il y
avait du danger du aurait laissé julie
tout seul du l'aurait abandonné bravo je
te félicite la raison françois renard en
lice allons-y
je lis tu sais je ne sais pas encore
mais elle a l'air bien triste
mademoiselle ne pleurais plus vous êtes
en sécurité ici vous voulez être gay
regardez-moi les droits des sports non
ça ne m'amuse pas rater tu cherches un
mouchoir pour être quasi mais oui en
fait qu'à dix heures tu sais bien que tu
n'as pas d'oubli toujours pourquoi
êtes-vous si triste maintenant on
commence à peler vous vous avez des
ennuis mais écoutez si vous le posez des
questions ont tous les deux en même
temps que voulez-vous qu'elle réponde
d'accord casimir tu as raison
mademoiselle
vous écoutez je suis arrivé dans les
enfants pour vendre mes jolies fleurs
mais s'il ya tellement de flop que
personne n'a voulu m'en acheter
mentionnons enfin évidemment vouloir
voir des fleurs dans l'île aux enfants
c'est assez ridicule qu'un pauvre des
parapluies en plein désert à tétouan que
dire que nous ne prenons pas gentil en
tout cas les fleurs seront bien arrosée
au diktat du must en prime j'ai une idée
mademoiselle menzel je vous achète
toutes vos fleurs oui j'ai des oeillets
des violettes centre edel des roses
voilà bon aussi nous lui proposions de
rester quelques temps dans l'île aux
enfants en juillet c'est une très bonne
idée en ce gentil je suis sûr que je
pourrai me rendre utile mais
certainement me réécouter pour fêter ce
bel événement je vous invite tous à
dîner
mademoiselle je connais deux ou trois
recettes de cuisine n'est ce pas qu'elle
veut dire dont vous me direz des
nouvelles
si vous me donnez vos fleurs j'ai
également une excellente des mots
débiner va décorer la table écoute
casimir la maison j'ai un grand vase du
mettra t fleurs dedans ça sera très joli
vous n'avez rien compris du tout quand
tu te poses que vous avez décidé
monsieur casimir gérard d'attendre pour
vous je reviens et bien voilà je vais
mélanger ses fleurs avec du sel du poids
de la mayonnaise de la moutarde ça fera
une salade délicieuse
[Musique]
ghazi nuit